[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey jeff
hey what's up how are you good yourself
i'm doing okay did you go to wendy's
before a knicks game when you were first
in new york first year as a coach
mcdonald's
oh so that's how i celebrated getting
hired
i i signed my contract and
stopped in the drive-through on the way
uh up the west side highway i don't even
think that mcdonald's is still there but
yeah that uh the number one combo never
tasted so good
but there's a wendy's across the street
though
and and paulie said that he saw you
there one time
oh it's very possible absolutely get the
chili are you kidding me i'm sure
uh that's all i wanted to ask you jeff i
just wanted to find out about that
uh are the knicks a good team or just a
good story
no they're they're they're a good team
that maxed out
uh the talent at hand in the
regular season and we see this every
once in a while where
expectations for playoff success rises
because of what happened in the regular
season but there's no question
atlanta has more more offensive talent
the depth of their talent is better that
doesn't mean the knicks can't win
but i picked atlanta i thought they were
a slight favorite going in
just because i think they have just more
weapons
offensively yeah i picked atlanta as
well i was also wondering about the
atmosphere because you coached in new
york and you coached
these were big games uh playoff games
but
can you did you ever were ever aware of
the surroundings
you know fan behavior while you were
coaching
not not necessarily the behavior but the
the
intensity and passion of the crowd
absolutely and i think
the garden was never louder than it was
in game two of this series i mean
it was overwhelming i've never seen a
crowd that i remember in the garden
standing an entire half and it looked
like the whole
place was standing up uh the entire
second half and i think
um so the crowd intensity and passion
yes
aware of i'll tell you i am a little i'm
very disturbed though by some of these
incidents
that fans becoming emboldened
to try to you know feel like they can
spit on
dump popcorn on that that's really
disturbing though
but i don't know what it is jeff are the
fans any different
i i mentioned social media plays a role
here but
are they more passionate uh
you know people trying to use pandemic
like oh you're being let out of the
house
like you're not going to your your job
today and spitting on somebody or
pouring popcorn on something like i i
don't know
what the reasoning is behind this well i
i would say
probably at a lot of places alcohol
plays a uh
a major factor i'm also disappointed in
the you know they're banning them from
the arena first of all
that's of no consequence because people
can come right back in
it's not like the people charged
or perceptually they're banned
they can't get in it's not like there's
facial recognition and they're get they
can't come in we don't even know who
they are
particularly with the trey young
incident spitting on someone
he should have the person should have
been arrested
like there there has to be harsher
consequences
for these type of actions and you know
but you're right like it's not that much
different some of the things said to
patrick ewing
um at road arenas i gotta say
like back in the night it it would
you know it today people were gonna be
would be like
stunned at how bad it was at times so
um i i don't know
other than alcohol how you can explain
you know
these bad behaviors but certainly
um a few people just you know it's
criminal activity is what it is
and i don't know how patrick was able to
just
internalize that i mean trey young
getting spit on
and you know you just and you got to
play a game
um i and i you know we've all been down
there with press row and you hear
what what is said or a football game or
basketball or baseball
have you ever had to say anything to any
of your players like hey stay in the
moment or don't let it bother you
uh i don't remember doing that dan but
i i gotta say like some of these things
like you shouldn't have you know they
have security behind the bench i think
this is where basketball is a little bit
different than football
football there's more separation between
the fans
and you know the players and in
basketball
particularly when we're you know not in
a coveted season i mean they're right on
top of you
and the things they say
or could do um you know make the
basketball players much more
vulnerable to two things and so
now i don't remember ever saying it but
i i gotta say that
sometimes i was actually stunned that
they didn't react
more often you know the idea when i
think westbrook went after somebody
um i remember way back vernon maxwell
went in the stands
after somebody you know i know they
shouldn't do it
but until you're in that situation where
people
you know can say these things because
they know they're being protected
by you know the rules and the league
will actually
you know protect the fan more often
times and they protect the players
i think it's try they're trying to get
better at it but we still have a long
way to go
he's jeff van gundy of the mothership
he'll be on the call nets and celtics
uh anyway the nets i gotta say i love
when you say
mothership that just makes me laugh each
and every time
go ahead i've been saying it for decades
i know i love it i love it
anyway the nets don't reach the nba
finals
well yeah there's a way
but to me they're the prohibitive
favorite i think
the path in the eastern conference you
know
they're going to have to play an
outstanding milwaukee team most likely
in the next round
if they're too advance if they're
advanced past the celtics
and then they've got to face a team they
most likely have to face
a terrific philadelphia team who's
great defensively and with a power
post-up player
that they really don't match up great
with so
yeah there's there's a course uh
and a path that they don't certainly
because i think the competition at the
top half of the east
those top three teams could all advance
easily to the nba finals if i gave you
the lakers
or the field in the west
wow if you would have said that before
the playoffs i would have said
the field yeah you know now like i see
them ratchet up that defense
uh you know if they're if they're able
to advance past phoenix
you know portland or denver denver
particularly because they're injured
i could i can't see either one of those
teams beating them
so you know it's their defense dan i
mean they're
they're big and they're tough and they
guard and
and when anthony davis you know gets big
numbers and he got james
uh you know neither one had a great
first half but they come out in that
second half and they just pound
you know a really good phoenix team so
i'd have to take la now that you said uh
you know if you'd pose that same
question to me i'm gonna i'm gonna
probably take la
what if the clippers bow out opening
round
what kind of ramifications fallout
inning if any
yeah unknown because i think kawhi
leonard could be a free agent
if he chooses to be
you know obviously i i don't really
understand
their messaging um
when people ask him after the second
loss is there any
concern and they said no concerns and
i'm like
like that's far different from saying
we're not panicked we're still confident
but to not have any concern i mean luca
doncic
in and of itself is a concern down 2-0
is a concern
um you know their inability to
to guard in a manner
in which like they should be a great
defensive team
they have every component you need to be
a great defensive team
so if i was their players i i i think
the proper messaging would be
yeah still confident but concerned we
need to be more
urgent uh you know we need to play
better
and i think this started with their
attitude towards the last couple games
of the regular season
where you know they lost
i don't want to say on purpose but they
certainly weren't playing to win
and the west is hard like dallas is no
joke
i mean i think they beat him by 50
earlier in the season so obviously
this is a really good team a dangerous
offensive team
and they've got a preeminent star in in
conscience
is there a younger a young player you
would take over
luca to start your team
well i'm trying to think off the top of
my head
but i'll give you first choice and if i
get i get daunted
i'm good i'm good with like it like
the way this you know what impresses me
about him
is as he's improved his shooting later
in the year
like when he gets into the lane he's so
big
so strong with such great vision
there's no great way to handle him in
the two-man game like in the pick and
roll
you can trap him and he can see over the
trap and he's a willing passer and they
have great shooting around him
if you drop deep in the lane with your
big
he's so big and strong that he takes it
deep and he can either finish or
make every pass necessary and if you
switch
particularly if you play a traditional
center
he just obliterates those guys so there
is no good coverage for him
and i think he's more dialed in he's not
a a
good individual defender per se but he's
more dialed in defensively
because he knows that ultimately you
have to guard
to win and so i think this guy is
a you know just a great great player i
mean he
if you put him as your mvp and many in a
ballot
i mean he's gonna be in the top eight
no question yeah he might turn out to be
like mike
trout where he's always in the
conversation for mvp the question is is
he
gonna win championships just like mike
trout mike trout
is you know obviously one of the great
players but he's not winning a
championship anytime soon
and luca may have a situation that's
similar to that
well so much of winning a championship
as you know dan is
who you play with and who you play
against
some some players were just born at the
wrong time
and even though they had good players
around him they just didn't have you
know
enough around them to win at all so you
know doncic
i think they have a very good team i i
know uh
they got off to a bad start this year
you know porzingis injury i think had an
impact i think doncic didn't shoot the
ball particularly well
but since rick carlisle has gone to
richardson off the bench starting hard
away with
finney smith klieba porzingis and doncic
that starting lineup is big it's
versatile
and it has a lot of answers at both ends
of the floor
you coached against jordan later jordan
you coached against kobe you coached
against lebron
a young lebron game plan wise who did
you
who did you figure out a little bit
better than the other two
there's no there wasn't there's really
no figuring out great players i think
what you try to do with all great
players dan
is you can't give them everything um
so for instance where we always started
off with game planning against great
players
you know first of all o'neill was by far
the hardest guy
like there was no game plan
for the power of o'neill so
but on those perimeter players what you
try to do is
take away transition layups and try to
take away free throw attempts
the pull-up game you know some of the
threes we see
lebron james making now off the dribble
he made one in game two against uh
phoenix you know left corner off the
dribble fade there's nothing you can do
with that
you got to take away layups you got to
take away free throws
and the harder you make them make it on
great players in the half court they try
to figure out
all right i got to get out and
transition more i got to get to the
offensive boards more
so you've got to fight them in the
effort areas but
there's truly no way to stop them but
you can't give them everything so for
james
you know like you can't give him 30
points and
double digit assists like you're he's
gonna get probably one or the other but
you can't give them both
it's always great to talk to you jeff uh
have fun tonight it's the nets in the
celtics that'll be at 8 30 eastern on
the mother ship
and uh sunday's game will be suns lakers
at 3 30 eastern on abc
if you can slip in mothership tonight
that'd be kind of nice well i think
we're on abc tonight so
you have to i think we are so
um i think tonight yeah it's an 8 30
game
because i think the other games are on
the mother ship uh
nick's come on at seven and i believe at
9
30 is uh dallas right
so two games on the mother ship one on
abc
and i if i i am gonna get mothership in
tonight
and mark jackson will probably uh
reprimand me immediately but that's all
right yeah i can i can handle that
yeah i wouldn't worry about mark jackson
mike breen's a hall of famer i'd worry
about him but uh
uh hey yes he is great to talk to you
jeff thanks for joining us that's jeff
van gundy we'll take a break
uh back after this